we got John zurka the master pickup
artist on all of YouTube right now he's
going to teach me some tips and we're
going to put it in action let's get
after it
I think the best game if you if you
really need to pick up a girl right here
is have a Ferrari have a Ferrari they're
all gold thingies right rent a Ferrari
pick them up and then say I can't pay
for that Ferrari use that content to
make money get more Ferraris run run all
the girls in Miami so the more Ferraris
the better once once you pull up and you
have 30 Keys blink blink and 30 Ferraris
are lighting up these [__] are
sucking on the streets and the best part
is you can get a [__] red uh what's
that called a red Honda a nice red Honda
and say it's a Ferrari and they actually
believe that these dumplings so I just
get the Ferrari sticker
put it on a Honda the [__] is so
confused she's only thinking of the
[__] horse is the horse the horse is
you the legs getting your dick sucked
so that's what it really is women are
gold diggers but for the more I guess
condensed advice is the Trinity of
network think of a YouTuber Network
status and looks when you say status
what do you mean like what kind of
status
blacksmith Crusader YouTuber not a
Minecraft Youtuber maybe a social
YouTuber but status just means you are
verified in your village towns
civilization right so what's your
identity who are you like let's say you
go on a date what's the most arousing
thing for a woman when you're on a date
is when people run up to take a photo
with you that status but now if they
take a photo with you and you're just a
Minecraft gaming cook
is it really status to her yeah kind of
but
yeah that's why I used to when I when I
had no followers I would get my boys
right to come up to you no I give them a
line of coke and I'm like you can get
another line but first run up to me and
ask for a photo
I'm with my [__] girl bro right
and she'd be like why do you only have a
thousand followers I go that's my burner
what's your real one later later I'll
tell you okay I'll tell you when you're
sucking my dick when she suck my dick
right as I'm busting I go
I got a thousand followers
I tell the truth because God wants me to
tell the truth right tell them the truth
but I don't tell them before getting my
dick sucked because then will it happen
you see what I'm saying it's an illusion
and the weird thing is this is not a
joke if you tell a woman you're a brain
surgeon a lot of them play along
just because it's a fun playful thing
like
this is real advice if you're at a bar
I nudge a girl I go hey yo my ex is
there pretend to be my girlfriend okay
okay if a woman actually pretends to be
your girlfriend at the bar for 15
minutes an hour two hours
anything they can role play they can
actually do and they'll actually start
falling for you does that make sense
yeah so anytime I'm out with the girls
I'll you can see in my content too I
always say nah this is my girl this is
my girl this is my girl and then she
starts memeing about it too later she's
like I thought I'm your girl so pay for
my bill when she's memeing she's putting
it out in the mental that's in her head
I'm [__] her if she's I'm building
imagery of [__] her and then I
immediately go hey that was fun guys it
was great I gotta go do big YouTuber
[__] and I walk away and she goes wow I
thought oh right he's not he's not
actually my boyfriend we're just
role-playing which is heartbroken
right so the number one thing on a date
you want to do set never never plan on
[__] even if she wants to but don't
even like insinuate it like in other
ways so like the boy you got to play the
emotional card so like the boyfriend
when are we getting married in the first
date all I do is talk about the second
date that's it that's the only thing
I'll ever talk about oh no next time we
gotta do that hike I'll never talk about
her coming over I'll be the first one
okay that's your Uber good night good
night and I'm the first to leave even if
I want to [__] I am so cold the first
date that she goes I'm broken I don't
like Circa but I need to win him over
and then I can leave him second date I'm
not like this I'm like hey baby I'm
touchy I'm right in it and she goes oh
my God he likes me now
but I'll never try and [__] the first
date because if you do get it the first
day millions of people do and they get
blocked and they go what the [__] I made
her orgasm I you still get blocked
because women respond to cats panthera
not dogs canis a dog wags his tail for
[__] oh my God we should you want to
come and say we don't have to [__] do
you want to come upstairs that's a dog a
cat is like this
I said this I said this in a video like
why lonely women love cats because they
have similar attributes to a guy no
[__] internet it's not just it's not
women when a cat hops on your lap you
feel honored because it hates everyone
yeah it's true but a dog is always on
your lap so I think the lower anxiety I
never talk to her like this bro I had
one chick say sit in front of me I left
the date I'll never do a date like this
I'm gonna always be like this side to
side right because I'm never as soon as
it's like this it's a job interview
that's why all pickup artists said the
worst place to take a girl on the first
date is the movie theater
bro my [__] the movie theater is the
best place because you get the whisper
in her ear yo Dwayne Johnson's wearing a
2-2 this guy's a [__] homosexual and
he's the Tooth Fairy what the [__] and
you whisper whisper and she's giggling
and now it's YouTube versus the movie or
if she's sitting here yo I think the
waiter is a homosexual liberal [__] it's
YouTube versus the waiter as soon as
she's on your team she likes you as soon
as it's like this now you guys are not
on the same team now it's like
confrontational and I never do what do
you do for work what do you no topics I
say your toes are like pedophile toes
they're so soft and she goes what do you
like to eat I go no I'm not a [__]
pedophile right so you just joke did you
see how he giggled at the pedophile
thing he's a guy so he's a funny
YouTuber it's not that funny but he
giggled she would be dying laughing at
that pedal thing and
it's always in a state of play I don't
say where do you work I never find out
where she works ever I don't give a [__]
if you keep a woman in a state of Play
psychically She interprets it as her
father no no you're keeping her young
you're keeping her young in a play means
young to them
she Compares you to the other dates
where she feels old talking about
politics and work now she they're called
chicks because they want a nest she
wants to come in the play nest of a
millionaire but if she's coming into the
play nest of a crypto guy talking about
crypto that's I made that [__]
mistake with the girl I was talking into
Miami I was explaining nfts yeah and
really ask yourself is it a Rousey
because you're either talking about
arousing things or Disney that's it so
all I do is I don't even know much about
Disney but I talk about Pinocchio for an
hour and she goes John why are we
talking about Pinocchio for an hour I
say because I am one of those wooden
creatures but mine's my talk when I lie
my [__] grows bigger and you're [__]
you're not that hot see how my clock
didn't grow I'm not lying you're not
that hot to [__] interrupt my
Pinocchio [__] she's dying laughing
compare it to a pickup artist who goes
that's really interesting Sally do you
really think that guy has any chance
pickup artists always say like get them
to talk about themselves yeah is that
[__] ninety percent of the date
should be you talking
the complete opposite away complete
opposite women on especially with a
stranger do not want that's why they ask
you what do you do for work what do you
do for it's always you
because she's not here selling herself
she's got a hole a portal that brings
life she's like the [__] prize right
in her head like everyone approaches her
so you're selling yourself to her to
pick her up right and hey we did that
podcast together
basically
[Music]
yeah you're in a mini you're in a mini
acting tough bro
basically the dates I do best in is 90
of me talking but not fast the best tip
shut the [__] up the best tip we're
ruining my [__] hunt on your [__]
RAV4 the best
advice and Derek Moore plays more dates
out of first when you talk to a woman
slow down you're talking but I add extra
things to it I actually don't listen on
purpose so she'll be like are we going
to eat and I go like this
what
and she goes oh he's not listening
anxiety is low are we going to eat the
women like I heard you talk about that
do they always rate me out of time rape
me
Napper oh you're in love so check this
out
by the way never approach like that wait
wait it's like too much energy but I
need the clip right yeah yeah but now
check it out I lean back when I talk
so if she's trying to tell me something
leave me close I actually lean further
away she comes closer closer what men do
is they go like this and meet her that's
[__] desperate [__] right one time I
was leaning so far back she fell on top
of me I go you horny as [__] it off you
and they love it yeah men always
intercept the girl you'll never see a
clip of me intercepting she's come to me
and I'm a passive cat on the windowsill
so if you have to remember it as
who are you on the date
dog dog dog dog
you're a cat
you are not interested in what she's
saying you're looking out this way and I
even checked their anxiety actively so
I'll be it's not just passive I'll be
like this
what are you so anxious about she's like
what I didn't even say anything I go no
no I can feel it and then they laugh and
then they check that behavior I feel
like that would make me like more
anxious if you said it yeah you think
she'd get more anxious if you said that
no no no I'm saying well yeah I guess
we're different but like personally if
someone was like you know when you're
baked and people are like bro like you
look [__] fried I'm like oh [__]
number one rule never smoke weed with a
girl I don't really smoke anymore
anyways the stoner Community totally
destroyed the dating Community because
they talk about that one time they
[__] the girl high bro when when
you're when you're both High she goes
wait what she heard someone call her
makeup ugly they hear [__] if you want
to [__] wine wine wine wine you'll [__]
wine is lowers inhibition it's all that
if you're gonna do something weed is the
worst thing with a woman especially an
edible where she's like oh my God all
the thoughts
huh yeah so the number one tip I would
say is
in my dating program it's D D direct and
dismissive you're cute we should [__]
and then she goes no I just met you and
you go
so that's direct I'll [__] but
dismissive I don't really care I like
you but not for long I like you but not
for long I like you but hurry up and
suck my dick because I don't like you
for long I like you but it's not gonna
last I like you I got options I like you
abundance I like you look at my DMs it's
[__] dumb [__] they're nothing
like you you're the best what's your
name again that's direct dismissive I'm
on a date night I forgot her name I like
you but I'm gone I like you you have to
come to me so that's all I teach right
and it's hot and cold right also another
thing I only break touch barriers when
she's laughing so with my date with
Jenna I broke it down on sneaker stream
where she goes I go shut the [__] up and
I slap or [__] and this is sexual
harassment so you're very intentional
like you're [__] constantly analyzing
but it looks instinctive because I've
done it for five years every single
night it probably is instinctive at this
point I just know yeah but I do check my
behavior like a lot of times because I'm
always in content mode I'm raising their
anxiety trying to get a clip and people
are like Circa your wrist was so much
better last week but I'm doing
everything I can to talk about George
Floyd you know what I mean so people
people gotta differentiate of when I'm
trying you have uh that look like
pedophiles
so if she heard that she'd be sucking
your dick okay that'll be a thousand
dollars here's my PayPal that'll be a
thousand dollars all right I'll send
that right over yeah yeah another thing
is never go out with friends to pick up
chicks yeah it's like a bunch of guys
that's a detriment I I used to I have 20
friends but the friends I like the least
were the pickup guys so we don't [__]
with each other they don't have really
my politics we don't get along at all
but we all know if us three team up
we're [__] everything so when we go
out we're not even like friends like
from 20 of my close friends the ones
that I least like are the pickup guys
because pickup is cringe but I they do
way better because pickup guys are like
this oh she's a lawyer bill is a lawyer
bill has the highest percent chance to
close
we lean back she says oh I do law and we
go oh really Bill aren't you like the
best lawyer you haven't heard of her
she's a [__] nobody so we immediately
give it to Bill even if we want her
because he has the highest closing
ability
when you go out with your friends they
don't know that so A lot of times they
go Circa this one's mine and everyone in
the group goes no no that [__] is a
[__] Latina circa's 99 success rate
with them especially because she's
[__] Circa diffuses those so if you
have a team [__] blocking you it looks
like you're taking turns trying to [__]
her and she goes well these guys are
losers what do you think like the girl's
friends like what importance does that
play
the girl's friends yeah I always talk to
the ugly fat one first make her laugh
get on her Snapchat so all of her
friends see me have a blast with her
then talk to the hot one and have a
small little not a Hiroshima just a
little blast so she goes whoa which one
does he want diffuse the [__] block
first and by defuse I mean one hour on
the clock block 10 minutes on the
kitchen what if the the fat one gets
jealous she won't if you if you spend an
hour with her she'll think you like her
yeah so the fat one will think you like
her then you start going to close on the
friend but you close on all friends so
it's not intimate okay what's your
number you're on Instagram and you and
you once you get all of them the last
one I save is the hot one I go you know
you're the one I want don't tell them
and she laughs because she goes whoa I
he defused she'll never go to the fat
one and say he said this to me she'll go
oh he's intelligent he defused my friend
because believe it or not even if the
hot one wants you she'll never have the
courage to tell the fat one ladies lower
the volume a little ten percent here
it's a little bit longer I have a
question you want to answer okay we're
getting get back here you have um Toes
that look like pedophiles yeah
oh she's laughing oh that's so that [__]
block but that one look at that one
she's caught talking she grabbed her
hand can I ask you John yes
come here
he just goes are you John me and my
brother used to watch it with like
[__] Alpha and like we would just
like years ago years ago on Twitch
hours I would watch you for hours that's
crazy excuse me do you want to answer a
quick question for a video what's up
with these shoes these are all crazy
okay no no I'm joking I'm joking I'm
joking teach me
come on look at them what about them
they're ridiculous looking look at these
shoes what do you think of her bro those
are like pedophile toes like what's up
with those or something I'm trying to
learn
I'm trying to learn how to get girls
yeah
it's not working it's definitely not
this it's not the roasting girls
teach me what are the most important
things in a guy that you look for
I'm the biggest racist online oh oh I'm
kidding I'm kidding it's all jokes the
biggest pedophile line actually real
talk hey woman how tall are you that's
Nico I have one oh look at this look at
that
you're like my daughter we could do like
daughter father role play are you into
that no I like your toes so she said the
most important thing in a guy with
loyalty loyalty respects
look I'm I'm respecting you I'm telling
you like let's get I'll get you better
shoes my shoes
are you on Twitter
you're not an influencer no you look
like a famous person oh thank you I
appreciate that you don't have only fans
do you no okay good
I can beat the [__] out of your ex okay
give me your number huh
okay all right what else is important
come here who's in my community so we
can find out if you're lying so don't
give me a favor what's your name
what's your name
it's very nice to meet you I'm Sunny
what are you guys doing just going out
to the bars yeah we're just going out
yeah
I'm 21. right
she's she's good enough to kidnap she's
so cute
you
always survived yeah I don't know about
this time
coming or something crazy this week I
just became a famous millionaire just
John Circle on YouTube
so like you have to date me you know
you'd be missing guys you're a
millionaire no he's famous because
you're famous that's his pickup line do
you have a job uh I do went out for the
summer because live with me I'm in the
penthouse at the Ohio okay
all right so I'll look you guys up on
YouTube it was great meeting you guys
it's great meeting you too no but you
can kiss mine
on the second day see you guys are we
actually going on a date right
all right yeah that was smooth but again
remember I sat back down after standing
if I kept standing did you feel the
anxiety build up because I knew the girl
walked away exactly inside them I did
that on purpose but if I wanted to do an
expert run I would lean back right hey
girls get on the YouTube come on what
are you doing you want to be famous look
at that
feelings
[Music]